Charlottesville had you know,
with,
with that,
with the,
with the initial purpose of protecting
the statue.
Was it good thing?
I don't.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I don't know about confederacy except
for the big thing,
but honestly it's a,
it's a slippery,
slippery slope and the confused souls
who and the bad just darkened soles for
sure.
Not Good.
They screwed up big time because the
purpose behind it is so important
because it's going to be fought founding
fathers next.
Anyone who ever contributed anything to
Western civilization as we know it is
already being.
It's already being done.
James Madison High School in the states.
It's getting renamed because some girls
from random,
one student felt unsafe and so yeah,
this is a serious issue and I wanted
like,
I feel like really up against the wall
now because now they found they're
Nazis.
Man.
The Nazis are flooding the streets now.
So how do we,
how do we possibly,
you know,
kind of save our cakes.
You had to bring it up,
didn't ya?
Well,
having the right degenerate into
identity politics does not seem to be a
part,
a positive solution.
So one of the things I would say is
that,
like I understand why the identity
politics that has been practiced so
assiduously and so you have a stating
Lee by the left has been cooptive by the
right.
I understand that.
But then here's what I would say to the
people on the right who were playing
that game.
If you play the game of your enemies and
you win,
you win their game,
you don't win.
That's not victory.
You just become the most successful
exponent of their pathology was.
How was that a good thing?
It's a bad thing.
So what does that leave people as old as
an alternative?
Well,
I don't think that the Caucasians,
let's say,
should revert to being white.
I think that's a bad idea.
It's a dangerous idea and it's coming
fast and I don't like to see that.
I think the whole group identity thing
is seriously pathological.
I think we've made big mistakes in
Canada.
I understand why at least to some degree
in that respect and that large mistakes
are being made all over the western
world where we're making your group
identity.
The most important thing about you?
I think that's reprehensible.
I think it's devastating.
I think it's genocidal in its ultimate
expression.
I think it will bring down our
civilization if we pursue it.
We be playing that game.
So what's the alternative?
You know,
I've thought for a long time about a
political career really forever since I
was like 12 really for a long time and
I've always decided against it because
it seemed to me that the proper level of
analysis with regards to the solution of
the problem that we're facing isn't
political and that's why I think it's a
mistake when what I'm doing gets
politicized either by me or others.
I think that the way that you deal with
this is to put yourself together.
I really believe that is that because I
think that individual people are far
more powerful.
There's certainly far more evil than
they're willing to consider,
but that's also a sign of their
unbelievable power.
So I think that what you do is you aim
high and put yourself together and stay
the hell away from the ideologues
because they're hiding.
They're hiding behind a wall.
They're not able to come out and fight
on their own behalf and so the way
forward through the logical mass,
and that's the lesson of Western
culture,
is to place the individual at the place
of paramount importance and to make the
group identity emerge only when
necessary and secondarily,
if ever.
And so you can do that.
You can do that now.
You can do that tomorrow.
Like you can put your life together.
And again,
as,
as I mentioned to the other young man
who asked the question is,
you won't hurt anyone doing that,
right?
You pick up your goddamn responsibility.
Certain yourself out,
fix up your family,
right?
And then you can be a force for good in
the culture.
And if enough people do that,
the ideological mass will just
evaporate.
It'll just disappear.
I think that's the way you show people
the right path forward to is that you
say,
well,
look,
um,
we would like,
we would like it so much.
If you could thrive as an individual,
drop your cult like affiliation,
right?
Step out of the shadows,
the demonic shadows your ideological
possession and step forward as a fully
developed person into the light.
Do it by example.
That's your.
That's your best bet,
man.
So that's what it looks like to me.
Thank you.